[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let everyone in the chat if you know the
chris pine movie with a very long title
please let us know in the chat
darkness
that's not long enough to wonder woman
1986
series of unfortunate events
welcome back to the break room everyone
our daily show that keeps you updated on
all nerdy news that you need to know
coming up today we got some new she-hulk
updates along with some disney plus
goodies goodies
and my baby will poulter as adam warlock
we got some little updates and we give
some good rated r disney movies just for
you to watch uh today we have erica wusu
[Applause]
[Music]
t.j
thank you thank you i'm also
no
not
10 years later that is a long title and
he is in that movie but no no he's okay
and we have brandon barrett who needs to
know this title hello christopher in the
world
sky captain in the middle he's not in
sky captain world tomorrow is he not no
that's jude law
okay well uh you're lying to me joseph
maybe i don't know today's redemptions
um is all about 1v1 dueling we're going
to go old school with this
old school artistic dueling that is
every 100 raise will trigger a contest
where uh
oh i'm sorry that's not me
random prompts will be pulled and the
best uh the best drawing of that prompt
wins you guys get to choose the people
but we get a random prompt and we're
gonna draw it you guys can all vote it's
probably gonna be me because i'm gonna
i'm agreeing what happens to the losers
the loser thank you for asking the loser
is banished to the penalty box where
they have to be yeah they sit back there
for two minutes they don't get to say
anything that's such a child game you
gotta sit over there
on monday we all know that um the
stretch goal if we get to two thousand
dollars by the end of the week where i
already have 1400 so we're well on our
way um the break room cast will be going
in full cosplay
yeah uh cbd which characters will be
playing but um
they have to be in the atomic cinematic
unit they do have to be on topics
speaking of tommy uh we have our tick
tock and we have our clip of the week
the break room is now on tick tock at
the underscore break room follow us for
more even even more break room content
um you will see the thumbnails and think
it's only tommy but i swear it's all of
us
also did you hear we have a mailbox what
say what say what message it's a digital
it's a voicemail
wait a minute mr postman hold up wait a
minute mr postman
check out our discord leave us a message
and you might get a chance to hear your
voice right here on the break room this
week we want to know your craziest
comic-con predictions we know it started
today but i want to know those dirty
dirty comic con predictions ones that we
haven't heard about ones that you can
create that we are like oh whoa didn't
see that coming oh we just want it
and we do want it but what do we want
more than that we want some headlines oh
give them what
headlines
on its website disney plus has confirmed
the release date for she-hulk as
wednesday august 17th we all know that
but they've also confirmed uh that
they're doing a weekly release of
episodes one at a time there's not gonna
be any bulk drops not two and one uh
they also in this announcements
reiterated that this is like a comedy
series it's gonna be funny it's gonna be
funny there's frog man in there there's
gonna be some serious but this is a con
they're like there's companies
oh my gosh it's so funny i altered your
genes and now you'll never be the same
i've destroyed your life whoopsie you're
irradiated you might oh it's electricity
it's funny you're being held by the
government without a speedy try i cannot
wait to watch this at nick yeah very
excited very excited uh our next
headline next headline uh miss marvel
directors adil al arby and baloffala
told the direct this week that there are
some great deleted scenes from the
series that they hope disney eventually
releases uh one of the things that we're
talking about is a scene where kamala is
like first revealed in her miss marvel
suit and then she gets hit in the head
with the basketball great uh and they
[ __ ] loved it uh they're like this
this is the funniest thing we've ever
seen why was we need they need to
release it they're like begging disney
to release this scene i don't know they
also talked about howard yeah they also
talked about some transition some cool
transitions they did that didn't wind up
in it but they didn't really say what
they were because they're like we might
use those again
we will be talking about some of this
deleted stuff at the end of the episode
so still yeah stay tuned to that uh and
i think they'll release some deleted
stuff they'll probably do an assembled
for they'll be assembled i don't think
we've gotten deleted scenes we've just
kind of
not like a standalone like here's your
one
one and a half minute scene right
usually with stuff in the background
that you could see or stuff that they
were filming yeah they haven't really
shown deleted scenes from my right
if we're wrong be sure to let us know in
the chat uh next headline disney plus
will be dropping all five episodes of i
am groot on august 10th uh but
apparently they already premiered the
first episode in front of some select
showings of thor love and thunder not
mine
it was getting good reviews everyone's
saying it's like fun and it's cute but
this is not going to be the heavy world
building you're looking for folks uh
james gunn is teased there's going to be
characters you haven't seen yet
they did get bradley cooper to voice
rocket in the first episode and you do
see rocket uh and vin diesel is of
course returning as as groot this is a
young group uh this is before infinity
war when he's still a baby uh but even
james gunn said that kind of like it has
its own canon
this is like
it's not necessarily canon he's like
please go on the broadcast
this is one of those morbius situations
where there were rumors that the
post-credits scene had been altered and
in a desperate attempt to get everyone
back to the theaters yeah this is like
straight comedy fun things these are
shorts they're going to release them all
at once but everyone's saying they're
cute they're funny
if i see him get kicked once i'm going
to turn it off protect baby groot was
kicking off earlier today
that's specious argument and i don't
want to allow it next headline hello
aspca
spiderman freshman year head writer jeff
trammell will be at marvel studios
animation panel tomorrow at comic con
and apparently we're going to be getting
our first look at the new project uh
yeah they hadn't they like left
off the list yeah things they were
bringing to comic con and the head
writer was like we'll be there
they're gonna maybe show a little stuff
i don't know if they'll show a sequence
or just some artwork but uh we're gonna
get our first look at what that series
is to look like stay tuned to the
channel eric is going to be doing a
recap of all the cool stuff that's
happening uh tomorrow at comic con we're
getting the marvel animation panel and
then on saturday he'll also be doing the
same thing so just keep your eyes out
keep keep your eyes peeled for that
little pouch and we also know that uh
jessica's favorite will poulter aka adam
warlock is gonna be at comic con so it's
very possible we could get it uh get
some very early looks i got into the
galaxy vol 3. yeah they just finished
filming that
yeah a couple months ago we haven't done
a couple months of photos right we
haven't gotten any we've just gotten
like nothing i mean james gunn trolled
with that swirly photo of the costume or
it was just a
blur and you couldn't really see i want
to see my man i mean if he comes out in
the costume that would be pretty pretty
hype
uh yeah i mean we we're talking about
this around the office so much they have
an animation panel tomorrow but their
main
panel is one hour yeah so and then in
the past
no i think it's just one hour one hour
it's five to six and then there's
something there's like a half hour
so they can't they can't hold too long i
mean in the past you know we know that
like they weren't gonna even be at comic
con they have their d23 coming up but in
the past like marvel's had like
stand-alone panels for each movie
they've had the main one with everything
and it was like two hours and they
trotted out everybody they could this is
one hour and we got will pulsar
confirmed but that's about it well we
don't even know if he's gonna be on
stage he's just saying he's gonna be
there and james gunn also sort of
tweeted some kind of indication that
yeah he was tweeting a little raccoon on
a scooter so yeah and he's going to
specifically said marvel you know i was
sort of like oh is this for peacemaker
or some dc thing but he said marvel um i
don't know we've got a poll going in the
chat 70 of you are saying yes we will
see adam warlock at uh
uh first look at um at comic-con we also
had a a poll do you prefer week-by-week
release for disney plus shows or all at
once 70 percent of you said week by week
i couldn't agree more yeah i loved
stranger things season four but uh i was
a little behind on it and i didn't get
to talk about it with anyone because i
was so far behind chris films with an 86
donation oh my gosh thank you so much
we're well on our way to comic-con
cosplay and a little bit of a draw off
but
oh my god that first dogs at fifteen
thousand dollars
they just bought us a used subaru
oh you subaru look it up um
did we did we hit the did we hit the
threshold yeah we did we did all right
and he's pulling right now great we're
pulling we're pulling for who you guys
want to draw off um while we do that
we're going to talk a little bit about
dc at comic con warner brothers has
their panel on
oh god it's at 11 a.m
on saturday no it's early um and
uh we know black adam is going to be
there we know uh shazam fury the gods is
going to be there but deadline had a
little article that came out that said
they was buzz that henry cavill would be
returning
as superman have you been seeing the
rumors that it's like he's going to show
up on the marvel panel they're going to
bring him up do you know how crazy that
would be that would be okay
only mustache no body
this sort of got a lot of attention here
in the office because the state of the
dc eu
i i don't know if we can
this super spread out this very small
font is all of the projects that are in
development at warner brothers right now
um
the state of the dceu is in a weird spot
right um
where zack sunder's justice league sort
of ended was like cyborg was [ __ ] off
to nowhere in particular barry allen was
just like running into the flashpoint
movie superman
like was in a trench coat and then he
like pulled his little trench coat open
and had his black suit on still his
little healing suit um and then you know
at the end we still got like lex luthor
and deathstroke for maybe like an
injustice league setup we had then that
like
new scene from that wasn't in the
theatrical cut with
um
you know like
with her we had marshman hunter yes
visiting um visiting bruce wayne we also
had uh that new scene with with jerry
letter joker and the dark side kind of
like apocalypse
so it's like okay where do these
characters go from here we know
darkseid's probably coming if we
continue with the zack snyder
justice league stuff we've obviously got
like
a lot of turmoil at dc to begin with we
don't we haven't talked about a lot on
this show but like all of the higher-ups
at warner brothers have changed in the
last six months
ezra miller is getting into a lot of
trouble
aquaman two has had some behind the
scenes issues we're not going to get
into it sure but then you also have like
things like joker huge hit for
uh dc the batman huge hit for dc not a
part of the dc eu or at least
through our understanding but then
you've got the suicide squad which was
also a huge hit um and suicide squad is
dceu right suicides and um i think they
both kind of are right i guess and then
you've got a peacemaker you've got
peacemaker and all these other shows on
hbo that are dc eu that are also doing
well and have james got attached and
they're moving forward um
and like technically shazam is the exam
black adam dc eu blue beetle dceu
batgirl coming to hbo max from the
directors of miss marvel is dceu yes so
with this new henry cavill announced i
know that was a lot of reason i know i'm
so confused
i was just trying to sort of explain
where the dceu is okay at this moment
which is to say still a lot of projects
in development
at this moment in time do you think dc
is planning
sort of
two
groups
two groups you've got the dcu on one
side we're gonna see where those movies
go we're going to see what audiences
think and then we've got this you know
joker the batman continuity which are
not necessarily in the same universe
but solo projects that are a little more
grounded a little more gritty um which
is funny to say more gritty than
right
but i guess with this news of henry
cavill potentially returning do you
think they're going to try to kind of
re-re-bubble up the dcu it does feel
like the the the meta right now is is
kind of pulling for henry cavill to get
another shot at it and that like he only
got one standalone superman movie never
got another standalone movie and it's
kind of like they did them dirty and
everyone wants it and it it but without
like batman coming back not or bat fleck
coming back it's like well you can't
really do that side of it i think
they're gonna finally because what we
talked about from um zack snyder when
they did the justice league they were
like we were prepared to recast um
henry cavill and affleck they were like
we were going to go in a different
direction
right after justice league so i still
think they're gonna and also now that uh
warner bros is taken over by discovery
or they merge with discovery i think
that's such a big thing for them to take
on that they're like we're going two
separate directions still because zack
snyder did still cast like gal gadot uh
jason mamoa henry cavill and baffleck
that it's like
we will se we will settle on this
eventually but right now we're going to
focus on our own direction and do a
different thing so i think henry cavill
coming back this is a stretch but i
think if that he is coming back as
superman it's not a zack snyder it's not
in that it's gonna be for the warner
brothers discovery so do you think it'll
be
uh
we talked a little bit in the office
about how the batman with robert
pattinson was originally going to be a
batfleck movie yeah um do you think
they'll take henry cavill out of the
schneider verse and have him do his own
superman film that is maybe not in this
existing continuity is that what i don't
for me personally i love henry cavill
but i just think they need to redo it i
think they need to start fresh on a
different page because as long as we see
him as superman i'm going to associate
him with the snack zach snyder snyder
verse so i think it'll be confusing for
a lot of people if it's like you
constantly see this one guy that plays
like quicksilver how we saw him in sony
and we see him in marvel it's like if we
had that quicksilver from sony in the
marvel one we're like oh okay they're
merging and it's like no we weren't
merging we're not merging it's just more
confusion i think yeah so that's
personally how i feel but i i do love
henry cavill do not get me wrong yeah
but i don't think we have this poll
going in the chat right now sorry to put
you on the spot dadson would you mind
making a poll asking the chat whether
they want cavill to be in the dceu or
sort of a separate kind of his own film
universe not necessarily tied to the
storytelling that's happening in that
does do we know if henry cavill enjoys
superman more than the witcher
because i also he has more to be allowed
to get in superman you know not that but
he can do it he's like very into the
witch he loves the witcher and he has a
lot of creative like he gets a lot of
creative pull in the witcher than he
does in superman so i and also someone
in the comments did say this and he
didn't mention how henry didn't want to
do superman anymore typecasting
and it's like maybe he does want to he's
okay with being like
let me step back well and it might be a
situation where his whole time there was
just not fun and he's having a ton of
fun with like witcher and he's like
maybe i don't want to go back to that
yeah i think that's the whole thing is
like it's dependent on whether or not
henry cavill wants to do something
anymore and if warner brothers dc wants
to continue with him because like it the
dceu is kind of broken but not fully
broken like we were saying they've had
successes with the
the
joker and the batman and stuff so i
think they'll continue to do those kind
of offshoot things and continue with the
dceu you got aquaman 2 coming we got the
flash movie coming so it all depends on
whether or not henry wants to put his
sword down and put the cape back on yeah
yeah
can i get one word answers from you guys
okay um
we saw a superman cameo in the first
shazam
neck down
will henry cavill cameo will superman
cameo in black adam yes
oh yeah
no
the contrarian response i kind of agree
no yeah
i just i think they want to
i mean
because they have to have a full out
they have i think we're still waiting
for like also there's another character
in black adam that i think we are not we
haven't seen yet um but
yeah i want him i think it'd be fun i
mean that would be shazam somehow you
need to tie something to something you
pull an amazing spider-man too right at
the very end of black adam superman just
like flies into frame and they fly
towards each other and just as they're
about to impact you cut to black and
you're like oh
maybe that's a review of that in all cgi
too you don't even need to yeah
definitely i mean we we did run a poll
about what dc property people want to
hear more about at comic con and black
adams ran away with 34 percent uh i mean
that's the other part of this story
right is that black adam is there's a
lot of rock talk right now yeah i'm
interested too and that poll uh
aquaman two was in dead last 15
which is similar to i think we ran
another poll
asking a similar question and and flash
was pretty far behind too so those two
projects don't seem super interesting
for for at least our audience um
58 of you said you want to see this
caval film in the dc eu i think people
like just like you know that serial
storytelling that we get from the comics
and i do love when you know multiple
stories from different places can come
together and yeah and be one cool thing
do we need to do this duel this drawing
duel you're right brandon versus jessica
oh
okay so i've got the prompts in thor's
hammer you ready you got your wrists
loose
this should be easy because i'm gonna
i'm gonna air a terrible visual so
there's no biases happening so i put
them in here and they're competing so
how long do we have to draw do you have
a timer ready i've got a timer okay so i
hand one to brandon one to jessica no no
we're both doing the same thing you can
say it out loud chad
gets to vote on who drew at the
beginning yeah yeah what do we think how
long can
uh eric and i vamp for a minute
one minute i think we could do that one
minute uh someone misspelled this but
the prompted tommy bechtel
oh tom uh ah guardian goats so as
gargoyle as guardian goats one minute on
the timer wait wait wait wait wait wait
i have to give me one second i just have
to remember what a goat looks like oh no
this will be easy me because i'm the
greatest of all time hey okay go
yeah no so i i mean look cavill coming
back is superman is interesting right i
think
for me
he's not been my favorite superman which
is
maybe
like like all time like even tv superman
he's not been my favorite superman i
know yeah i think he's been a great
superman i mean he looks the part he's
jacked as all hell i think maybe it's
just superman in general has always been
don't please don't come after me a
little a little bland yeah
hopefully that's gonna go crazy on that
one
um talking to you the other day about
how i like superman i grew up on the
kyle make something yeah you said it was
your favorite hey yeah oh no i'm talking
to someone else
another red and blue hero but i think if
they they gave 14 seconds another uh
interesting story to do in the movies
that would be really dope like yes
there's a graphic
comic superman world piece or something
like your time is up but you have until
eric finishes his story yeah superman
world peace that was a super interesting
um uh
piece of literature about superman where
he is basically like i'm a solve world
hunger and a bunch of dictators around
the world are like i need people to
suffer so you couldn't really do it i
think you know that plus or maybe like
an all-star superman
story yeah that that uh that movie that
came out where he was dying and had to
fly to the sun that would be really cool
on film we already got that in eternals
we don't need people flying into the sun
i'm finished okay time
here we go
i i mean i have my whoa
okay camera four great
terrific
blah i like that
brandon you wanna yeah yeah here's mine
those are four great goats these are
these are two goats well both i think it
goes these are two goats i'm talking
about all all the time
one of them's got the curly horns you
can see they're drinking beer
because they're asgardian also this
arrows said they're asgardian
and uh
they're goats
as guardian goats look at the fur so
realistic
so realistic i like your beards though
um these are my goats they have beards i
didn't have to indicate that they're as
guardian because you can see
and they're screaming and one's going
and one's going
and they're bearded nice
i'm sorry how do they sound again
and the other one goes
wonderful
okay put your put your winners in the
chat uh every dollar that you donate
today goes toward excellent costumes for
comic con just so everyone says comic
con 2022 just so everyone knows just so
everyone knows um while you're voting we
also wanted to thank some of the folks
that helped
bring you the break group every day
every day we want to thank our friends
at better help for sponsoring the break
room this week tommy recently decided to
speak out seek out therapy after some
really stressful news he's been talking
about it all week this week um we know
that like life is full of twists and
turns many of us here at new rockstars
have a therapist seek therapy
we think it's a really healthy part of
your whole sort of health journey
it's important to show up for yourself
you know while you're going through
difficult times and even when you're not
going through difficult times therapy
can be super helpful better help online
therapy will
assess your needs
excuse me and can match you with your
own licensed professional therapist in
less than 48 hours
you know
a lot of us here have started and
stopped therapy a lot of times in their
adult life i know right now i'm not um
in therapy right now and it's been
really hard trying to sort of find a
therapist that makes sense for my life
and better help is a great place you can
go to to get a little bit of that help
it'll be a lot it'll be very easy um so
if you're struggling and you need to
talk to someone better help is a quick
and easy way to try therapy for the
first time or jump right back in it's
not a crisis line it's not uh it's not
self-help it is professional therapy
done securely online available to
everyone worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions you don't even
have to be on camera if you don't want
to um you know sometimes you just don't
want to watch people uh you don't want
people to watch you cry
and getting therapy every week is as
easy as a few clicks on your laptop or
your phone and right now if you're
interested they have a special offer for
our breakers for our roomies to get 10
off your first month you go to
betterhelp.combreakroom
so for 10 off your first month of online
therapy go to betterhelp.com
break room who won the poll it was a
tight one it was a tight one down the
winner
you guys can see the results i can see
the results surprisingly this is jessica
problematic
disgusting
[Music]
[Laughter]
go ahead you know what it's better that
brandon misses out on this because this
is my favorite part of the show it's
mandatory fun
[Applause]
just like me play it again
thank
you
oh my god i'm sorry did you guys hear
that it must have been the breeze must
have been the wind saying playing for
the third time baby daschle hit me again
one more time playing for a third time
you know what i'm not gonna go to four
because
why would we ever go to four
oh my god but you didn't see that coming
bet you thought you saw the last one
[ __ ] okay so a little birdie told me
the deadpool one and two not just one
one and two along with logan
will be moving to disney plus tomorrow
comic con week everyone
it's like christmas merry christmas
everyone
tomorrow both rated r movies which is
kind of insane but just like ryan
reynolds tweet that he posted i think
like today there's a whole lot of other
movies disney has released that should
be rated r pete the magic dragon didn't
they want to eat the kid wasn't there a
whole song about eating that child
rapunzel entangled lived in the worst
life in a with an abusive mother for
like 16 years that's why we're talking
about the original uh rapunzel which is
the deeply the western market the
brother the brother's grim one yeah
what did we say you're on
out god even banished and he keeps
talking uh and don't even get me started
with the [ __ ] that's pinocchio all
right starlight
like the horror that is tom hanks
playing in japan
so i wanna hear from you two
not three you two i want to know what
your rated r disney movie is like what a
rated r scene maybe even a new rated r
remake if you want me to go for i can go
first if you want an example
i'll set the stage you guys one of the
most rated r movies that should have
been rated are
to me
is um
is hunchback from notre dame
[Laughter]
actually there is the same hercules but
i'm talking i'm talking hunchbacker
notre dame that movie is so intense and
as a child i said hellfire is my
favorite song growing up i recognize
hellfire was a man that was having a
heart
oh his timer's off he's allowed to come
back
i hate him back from uh banishment um
and i want a rated r i want the real
rated r movie that is the hunchback of
notre dame you want the book the with
the book i guess yeah the book i guess i
want it to be so horrific i wanted to be
game of thrones i want us to be looking
in the musical stylings of um
history of the world part one
i want mel brooks to write the songs so
it's a little campy but i also just want
game of thrones style if you don't abide
by my rulings i'm gonna cut off your
head i love that
in the real book most of them all die
they all die and also i think quasimodo
dies i think quasimodo does
spoilers his back was too high but hey
no we don't do that
we don't do that here
we don't do that here yeah his back
wasn't hunched enough that's right
but if you go back and watch over the
hunchback of notre dame please
please go back and listen to the lyrics
of hellfire oh so good that song is
it's a man that's like i need her and
want her but i can't it's her fault and
i'm like okay settle down yeah let's go
back to your thread
yeah support that also yes so game of
thrones style hunchback of notre dame
who's next who's next uh i'll go next if
that's cool
go please yeah uh i think what movies
should be rated r that's a disney movie
uh i'll go with the disney channel
original okay cause those count
johnny
tsunami absolutely
into an r-rated film how uh it should
just be an explicit triple x hardcore
porn
nice to know
all over the place
when your parents came down to the
basement and you were getting older you
know that's one of the things that
helped my computer screen look like a
one game of solitary oh my gosh yeah i
need more details that wasn't enough i
gave an entire thing about that oh joe's
oh my gosh he's just blowing backs out
on his
all right sorry
um
here's the thing the movie that's made
me cry the most times in my entire life
is 2016's wild starring reese
witherspoon not a disney i love
the them most number of times is toy
story three oh okay when they're all at
bonnie's house at the end of the film
and they're playing with andy for the
last time tears instantly but if you
rewind it back a little bit the scene
when they're in the little trash the
incinerator the incinerator before the
clock comes to save them and they're
facing their deaths here's what i think
should happen
they die
and the incinerator is just
foreshadowing and now they're in
the seventh circle of hell and it's
about all of these toys who are stuck in
the house cause they have souls yeah
because they have false okay they're
stuck in hell and they have to fight
their way out blood sweat tears betrayal
dismay
uh torture yeah uh it's horrible um
wouldn't it be funny if there were like
little tiny little toys who were jews
could be
living inside of
satan's hell and trying to you know make
their way back to andy that's what i
want so
battle world yeah okay really quick
shout outs to the chat we got uh vance
washington with johnny pune
ah yes
chicken fire
freak i love it
that said uh d2 mighty
fox
frozen in the style of the boys from
chickenfox449
oh perfect i love it
i should have written that down move on
as a r-rated movie i mean we all want
that everyone in that movie is hot
they're all underage
gosh oh my gosh you two need to go we're
just talking about this guy
we gotta go to horny jail back yeah
we were talking the other day about
disney princesses and like mulan and how
mulan is like the disney princess with
like ptsd because she like went through
the wars and stuff she was killing
people oh yeah and like she would be a
crazy disney princess great stuff we've
got a mythology fact from chrissy who
says in norse legend loki cut sif's hair
and his and is forced to create her
beautiful crown as penance while he made
the crown loki has also created other
magical items including mjolnir not a
rated our disney film chrissy just a
random mythology fact which counts
when he's in the room with stiff over
and over and she had cut his hair all
right he had a hair we got another
chrissy that says rated our high school
musical is euphoria with songs oh it's
just it's just cindy
am i dressed like [ __ ] oklahoma
[ __ ] you better be joking
i have never been happier
ever been happier brandon uh
my there's so many good ones to choose
from guys uh and as you insinuated most
of the original like hans christian
anderson and brother grimm stories like
cinderella you have people cutting off
their feet to fit into the glass zipper
uh i think the little mermaid gets their
legs cut off too to become the little
mermaid good lord all right some dark
stuff also whoever wrote this intro and
wrote pete's magic dragon you're
confusing pete's dragon with puff the
magic dragon true it was the magic two
separate
which one's the one that tries to either
kid or the parent the family's trying to
eat the child
i think that's
that's the donner party
[Laughter]
but i think the most like r-rated thing
i would like to see explored in disney
uh in the cars movies which i don't even
really like but in cars 2 they
established that there was a world war
ii in cars land uh and this has been
gone on in the internet so i'm this is
nothing new to you but like the idea
that there is like
i want to see a full like normandy beach
landing of cars
with like cars just getting like ripped
open with machine gun fire a car walking
around holding its muffler being like
just like the utter destruction and then
i guess because you've said that like
the boats are sentient too you have cars
inside of the boats going on to the
landing and then you have like the
planes which are also sent in one of
these planes has an atomic bomb inside
of it so that one plane the enola gay of
of the uh cars world had to drop the
bomb i just want to see that sequence
like played out that's a great war and
cars cars because i imagine them to be
like the trolley like the cars of that
time too so it's just like an old asthma
bill just like being carried from like a
helicopter yeah yeah oh my gosh that's
that's the darkness i would like to see
on disney plus i if t michael bechtold
was here um i would absolutely
agree i would give this to him and he
would green light them away but as his
former assistant we didn't get along
well
believe it or not me and him did not see
eye to eye uh i'll have to i'll have to
take this to the heads up myself so go
ahead in the chat let us know which ones
you guys think are the best i love all
these rated r uh everything clockwork
orange that you guys keep putting out
there pinocchio
um yeah great idea
let's make sure
disney sees it the pole seems pretty
tight though jessica seems to be pulling
away come on guys vote for johnny to
johnny it's actually not that close
brandon
in second place
johnny
[Music]
i'll be honest pretty disappointed in
everyone at home
i will never do the show ever again
johnny i love it i love the cars one the
cars one i would actually i hope they do
like i see some some uh you want
mercedes-benz
the car yeah yeah yeah oh some darkness
some real dark war okay that's enough of
this fun
conversation look we got some really
cool new we teased this earlier on the
show we got some really cool new concept
art from miss marvel um and we
think
it's showing off what the newer
dimension might have looked like right
if we had actually gotten there um can
we throw up some of those images uh that
looks like inside of some kind of crazy
weird temple thing in the newer
dimension we've got one oh that also
looks like it's inside of a temple thing
and then yeah right then we've got who i
assume is kamal but could be a different
character sort of looking at an entrance
across some sort of lake or something
in this crazy realm and then this is my
favorite of the bunch of them if you see
in the bottom there she's like
hard lighting over there to
a similar looking entrance we assume
since this is concept art they just like
didn't quite have the final look for
uh what it would look like and these are
probably supposed to be the same place
so
um
that's pretty sick i'm sort of sad
is that dope it's pretty awesome
sweet
um
here's some of the questions that i had
uh off the top of my mind first of all
um
the whole
villainy stuff in miss marvel
i think we all talked how much we loved
the show if we all had to give one
critique probably it would be like the
confusing i was at least a little bit
like okay who's the real villain of this
show is it the dodc is it comrade is it
the clandestine
there was a little bit of confusion for
me there
uh
my sort of inference at looking at these
images is maybe they had this sort of
plan for
episode six and the clan dustin were a
little bit more a part of the show yeah
they were gonna go to the nord dimension
at the end and sort of like have a
showdown
there um
but i really liked the ending that we
did get so i'm torn do you guys have a
preference one way or the other if you
would i mean obviously like this is a
very cool location that we would have
liked to have seen but you have a
preference one way or the other you like
keep it the way that it ended do you
think this would have been a cool
direction to go in i mean
go ahead no go well i don't think
they're ever gonna go back to the nord
dimension and never talk about it ever
again so like i'm fine with how it all
ended then if it's not important enough
to exist going on past this point then
it's fine we never go there if we do
eventually need to go there in the
marvels if they explore it more that's
great
that's fine too uh but yeah it does feel
like
they
had this idea and they're like this show
will be about kamala khan getting our
powers and interacting with the
clandestine the end and then
someone came in and was like hi you need
to include the dodc in this and like i
feel like that's how the ending kind of
shifted uh a little bit so
if
if they want to go back to the nord
dimension they can but if they're never
gonna go back then i'm fine that they
left it out i will say in terms of her
character i do like that they kept the
stakes a little bit smaller she's still
a 16 year old girl who got her powers
right right um maybe sending her into
this like crazy realm with this sick
looking entrance that i'm gonna steal
for a dmv campaign uh you know felt a
little too big for where she was in her
character development did you have
something you you wanted to bring up
i was going to say that i agree with
bran
i agree with brandon but um
that and also the fact that they wanted
to do a lot more but kevin feige was
like no don't
ask too many questions was like just
stick to the family um just establish
her or like origin basically and just
like who her family is in love so i
think they probably did want to do more
but they were probably stopped and it
kind of shows a little bit in the show
where it's like you guys wanted to dive
into this but we didn't and why didn't
you so it's like you get a lot of you
hit a lot of brick walls i think you're
referring to the story that we talked
about the other day where uh they were
asking do we think any of her family was
uh snapped or dusted yeah the rest of
the article was him going on to be like
just focus on this okay but we didn't
talk about that that much yeah because
it is weird that you and like in this
show
the clandestine shows up and then they
get like arrested by the dodc but are
immediately free from it the next
episode so it was like this weird thing
of like it did feel like the dojc was
added later
uh and then kind of like put into the
ending what i did like about that
concept art is that temple it does feel
like separated it's separated from the
land she's got a hard load across it
almost looks like a spaceship and like
the interior of it was like much more
techy looking than i thought it would be
and the idea that like can we show some
of these images the uh the idea that
like maybe if they were going to go the
inhuman route that like the cree made it
to the nord dimension or something and
that's where they were making in humans
it wasn't on earth like the inhumans
were aliens from this other dimension
that the cree were experimenting on i
don't know like that looks like some
very supreme intelligence stuff oh so
just seeing the concept doesn't mean
we're not going to see it again right
exactly i'm not sure they're gonna
explore and the marvel is great if it
you know if that's if if it turns out
like the whole mutation thing it looks a
little like some weird stuff leaking
over from the nord dimension i mean that
might be how they explain mutations and
mutants i don't know yeah yeah and it
would have been cool to see a light
battle in this light dimension between
comrade and kamala but i feel like we
got so many good elements in that final
showdown if you can call it a showdown
uh in new jersey
uh where cameron got a handle of his
powers and she put up that force field
around them that like we yeah we didn't
really need that
other dimension as a locale for ms
marvel in this series because she
already went to pakistan like she's been
all over the place so i think localizing
it to new jersey for what we got in
episode six was
great do you think and this is sort of
like outside of canon but talking about
the production stuff a little bit do you
think that with the release of eternals
and chiang chi you know in eternals she
meets eresham and they go to that sort
of like weird creation place and then in
shanghai they're going to
tallow do you think that they were like
we've sort of done the like
go to a realm thing in a couple of
movies yeah i mean they had just done it
in multiverse of madness too right yeah
it was like it was all about like
jumping realms and then bleeding over
and incursions it did seem like it was
like oh you got a great idea we love it
it's very similar to everything else
we're doing right now i mean uh uh can
we say this yes um we we're friends with
a lot of people at marvel here and and
that writes some of the stuff that we
love um i have heard from some people
that like
they they are aware of that and
sometimes they're writing a show and
kevin will be like hey no that's
actually going to be a thing that we're
doing like in six months right when you
don't know about it but you can't do it
even like even like two characters like
you know meeting a certain guy is like
oh we kind of have a scene that's
similar to that yeah i mean we see it
with the concept art too where they're
like they just plug characters in the
concept art yeah they're like can we
have deadpool in this and they're like
no absolutely
right absolutely spoiled again so i
guess like you know we we don't really
know where where miss marvel is going
next i mean we don't know where she is
currently after that post-credits scene
do you think that brandon doesn't think
we're gonna see the newer dimension
again do you think it's a possibility
for the marvels i think uh no
um but i also uh i have i have a feeling
that the nor dimension is just another
similar dimension somewhere else and we
just know it as a nor dimension i feel
like it's the same reason how like they
were like we're the gin and it's like
well some people call you other things
so i think we'll see it as something
else maybe that's possible it could be
like an ether situation in sort of the
dark world where they're like oh that's
an infinity stone don't worry about it
we just called it something else in this
movie well i said a different color i
said the other day if the nord dimension
turns out to be the negative zone right
that's what it is right and you know
like in the marvel she's like you know
they're like nor dimension i'm in the
north dimension and it's like actually i
mean the negative zone
[Applause]
and that would make sense why the bands
are like mega bands right because
they're tied to the negatives that's why
she goes
that's our favorite line of dialogue
tomorrow put it on her shirt
i do want to get to some of our super
chats before we wrap up today a tighter
show while we're waiting news from
comic-con this week um tomorrow's show
is going to be lit as
[ __ ] i can swear this is my show
um this is your show ernest i decided
today ernest esteman says a little
mermaid should be rated m a i know y'all
remember the old school vhs cover that
is very true and that marriage ceremony
scene with the priests you are horny as
hell you're seeing things
too of her up on that rock
well i mean that's water behind yes
it was a very formative thing
is a little mermaid the one where
everyone was like oh you can see the
outline of something phallic
yeah he's talking about the priest in
the temple well the temple the temple on
the vhs one of the spires is very
phallic looking and then the priest
he's a short man on a box it's this knee
but it kind of looks like a
regular-sized man uh
happy to be there
wearing loose-fitting robes good for him
i mean eric vosset bitted that uh ursula
getting large was a very formative
moment and he's getting in his life no
it was not giant
look up the road
he's getting married
theory he said it and he was specific it
wasn't just ursula it was bigger people
that are like always connecting their
disney to like their awakening moments i
mean i'm an older man though a lot of
you and i was at the right age when the
little mermaid was a major and it was
very formative stuff in here
[Music]
shout out to td jones who says very
little but as always they're sending us
a couple of doubloons yeah thank you for
making it thank you comic-con better and
better that's right
murray in the mix says henry cavill is
captain britain question mark oh i mean
that would be a major pool yeah a major
pull by marvel real estate to get him in
as captain brooke he shows us literally
last minute to the panel and kevin feige
goes henry
it's blaze
and blaze i mean it would be great you
have captain carter and then off screen
your hair like you're holding my shield
and like in comes every caval as an
angry captain britain we do know captain
britain technically somewhere out there
in earth616 there's that little easter
egg in in end game uh where
uh
i don't remember
this guy this guy's trying to make up an
easter egg no no no no go watch her
breakdown he's trying to make him like
an easter egg yeah like captain america
goes back in time to the 70s like hear
someone say here's i don't know whatever
who cares uh
sounds like jasper trying to get
something going um but i say mr stuck
how about we power up one of these
bridges gentlemen and howard's like get
the [ __ ] out of here you landed bastard
we shouldn't let you die in world war i
jarvis
both of them no okay i love jasper
the friendly uh
the less friendly ghost
john sukis says will we see news about
daredevil or punisher at disney plus uh
for disney plus at senior comic con i
hope we get berenthal back asap punisher
seems the least likely
other than iron i know we talked about
punisher a lot
yeah i know
i mean if if they do punish you they
gotta bring burnt all back and it's
gonna be hard r like logan yeah that
would be dope well that would have been
an interesting point right we've got uh
we've got logan deadpool i think it
means something it's coming tomorrow
right before they do their work
those kinds of movies for hulu but
disney plus internationally is partnered
with star on a lot of countries and some
other services in other countries but
internationally disney plus has r-rated
stuff all over it it's it's america
where they've kept it separate so far
but america is also the country that
would complain the most you know what i
mean um
let's see louis berry sent in a super
chat and and they said i want capital
back in adam shazam to flash
superman could could go underwater he
doesn't need to
breathe zach i could just go down there
and mess around
name a better superman i don't want to
hear from zach i don't know he called
you out be on the show never better
superman be on the show never better
superman than henry every other superman
every other superman
yeah you're right but not better than
cowboy i like the tyler
i can't pronounce it
from lois and clark
it's me just
like dean is a better superman
here's what i'm saying about the
superman thing and then i gotta put it
to bed because people are gonna start
tweeting at me
uh i remember i literally remember
if my friend david enriquez was watching
right now i was in college when the man
of steel trailer came out and we both
separately were watching it in our dorm
rooms and we finished watching it and i
sprinted to david's dorm room and i was
like did you see the man of guilty and
he was watching it as i ran into his
room the just like the hype surrounding
that film
was so huge and the trailers were so
spectacular i just felt like uh we
didn't get a movie that lived up to the
trailer for that film and maybe that's
me putting expectations on a film that's
unfair i hate to say it but you need to
go watch a little bit of the cw
you need to go watch a little bit
because i like tyler oh i cannot
pronounce that last name but i like his
i like his you like him so much i like
his superman i like his superman and
looks well it's pronounced it's like
hoachling hoytlean
i think he's a great actor i just think
okay uh we got a different super chat uh
louis berry again says hopes uh for the
marvel pant oh no hopes
can't there were condoms forever
and then the haircut yeah
asparagus berry or louise berry has some
hopes that are i i'm so sorry
anyone really want to see the david
erica of suicide squad haven't we done
enough i think it would just be fun to
watch
david air has said
there is no air cut right because i
think he knows that like
[Laughter]
[Music]
the original one wasn't that great oh
johnny really quick johnny cashew in the
chat said henry cavill is awesome toss a
coin to your
krypton i will toss a coin baby all
right toss a porn to your witcher oh
that was a piece of paper i'm terrified
um let's see uh
wow split 50 50 in the polls is the nord
dimension and the negative zone the same
place
someone called feige guaranteed 55
percent of you
okay again first off if you had any
connections with kevin feige i would and
waited something right now
is watching right now he's getting ready
for comic con
his hand and merit to his hat and
marriage and he keeps saying no he takes
the hat off wipes his brow puts it back
goes jessica's got me sweating and then
he puts it back on
i'm just trying to get that money
um
ai sween says i need feige to come to
the stage and announce that he's doing a
live action
i can't read from this far show and jump
universe what is that shown in jump
shots oh some anime stuff oh
oh
oh we got some cool anime news this
weekend do people can we get a poll in
the chat from dawson who out there is
like super into anime we don't know if
we should cover that on this show but we
will if you guys are into it um super
into anime not so much into anime uh or
don't watch anime really an anime is the
mcu in dc eu yeah i'm very curious um so
some of us here at new rockstars love
anime some of us haven't gotten into it
yet i love the idea of anime oh okay i
love all anime you're so horny i figured
you'd be all over it see this is what it
is i'm still riding the hive that's my
worst friend dragon ball z yugioh
pokemon those are my shit's back yeah
i'd be pretty good right they're all
still on christy says if feige is
watching he should hire me oh god the
chat's moving too fast everyone's in the
end there's no poll yet about yeah he
should hire me even though i may not be
marvel shaped i don't know what that
means uh chrissy for recasting oscar
isaac in moonlight confirmed
okay the polls going the polls going
everyone's saying yes
um
on the break room if we did talk about
anime we might get i see this camera
hasn't changed thank you daschle uh if
we do talk about anime we could have
some guest appearances and when i say
guest video appearances i mean mt and i
are very much into anime talk about it
the guest is going to be empty yeah
everyone asked for them why not get
around here oh well i meant like mt tell
them to come to los angeles or maybe an
mt can just do uh anime
sidebars yeah
uh
people are people are split here we got
57 saying that whoever voted
honestly more people than i thought
would you rather us cover anime or uh
game of thrones house of dreams or or
barbie or barbie the answer is barbie i
will hear you
there's nothing else we will be covering
both house of dragons yeah and
uh
for the rings it looks like probably
probably it looks like a little bit of
both feeding shows little bounces all
the no's are bots you guys it's okay
it's okay if it's a no you guys don't we
can we can be a little anime babies yeah
yeah yeah yeah i don't really like him
he's a bot he's a
you guys thank you so much for watching
the break room thank you for sticking
with us this week we're going to be
doing comic-con coverage today obviously
tomorrow uh marvel has their animation
panel so we're going to be looking at
some of the stuff that they put out
there on saturday we're going to be
doing a special show 5 p.m pacific time
uh jessica clemons is going to be here
eric woo is going to be here zach
huddleston is going to be here i might
make a guest appearance who knows it's
going to be wild we're going to talk
about the warner brothers panel that
happened earlier in the day we're going
to be live uh discussing with you guys
what's happening at the marvel channel
yeah and then we'll be back on monday
for tomicon comic con on monday folks
thank you so much we love you guys to
death um and we'll see you tomorrow
bye